CRAIG MCLUCKIE: All right.
Welcome everybody.
Oh, a little bit loud.
I'm going to take a little
bit of time to go through
something that was announced
today, which is
Google Compute Engine.
During the keynote, Urs
introduced our new
Infrastructure-as-a-Service
product to the
Google Cloud platform.
I'm going to take a few minutes
to elaborate on some
of the stuff he shared
with you.
He showed how Google Compute
Engine has been used by the
Institute for Systems Biology
to take a life-saving cancer
research process and move it
from something that took hours
to minutes to seconds.
I'm now going to take a little
bit of time to share with you
how Google Compute Engine can
offer you that same set of
capabilities, how you can
tackle some really big
computing problems on Google's
infrastructure.
And during the session, I'm
going to provide a very broad
brush stroke sense of what
we've been up to so you
understand what the product
looks like.
I'm going to invite some of our
partners up on stage to
share some of their experiences
and the
technologies that they're
offering.
And I'm also going to give you
some demos so you can actually
see the product in action.
So let's jump right in.
Google Compute Engine is
Infrastructure-as-a-Service.
So when describing this product,
I think the logical
place to start is with Google's
infrastructure.
Now, as you know, Google runs
some very big internet-scale
businesses.
And to be successful in these
big businesses, we need a
really large infrastructure.
The process of running
search, for instance.
We index every day billions
and billions of web pages.
Our Caffeine index is over
100 million gigabytes.
It's huge.
And we're able to provide
results within a quarter of a
second to those search
queries.
To do that requires some very
interesting infrastructure.
To be successful as a business,
it's not just about
the size of the infrastructure,
the
performance of the
infrastructure, the scale of
the infrastructure.
It's also about the efficiency
of infrastructure.
And the efficiency to us is
important for two reasons.
One is environmental
impact, obviously.
We're very green by nature.
And our data centers actually
consume only about half the
energy of traditional
data centers.
But it also translates
into money.
And it means more
profitability for the business.
So we have spent a tremendous
amount of time and effort
innovating relentlessly,
focusing on bringing new
capabilities to market
and new technologies
to market for ourselves.
And we've also focused on
refinement of every process in
our data centers, whether it's
the design of the hardware
down to the silicon; whether
it's our software-- and we've
brought some really neat and
interesting technologies to
fuse together commodity hardware
and provide very high
quality of service offerings
on top of it--
to our data center design.
Whether it's dealing with
cooling; whether it's dealing
with power distribution; or to
our operations, rolling out
new infrastructure, doing that
efficiently, dealing with the
life cycle of our hardware,
recycling it.
So we've relentlessly
refined across this.
And what we brought together is
this incredible power, this
incredible scale, and incredible
efficiency.
And now you can access that and
run your processes on our
infrastructure.
So what is Google
Compute Engine?
At its heart, it's
Infrastructure-as-a-Service.
Infrastructure-as-a-Service
starts with Compute.
We provide Linux virtual
machines that you can rent by
the hour on demand.
You can configure them the way
you want, and you can run
traditional workloads
as if it was running
in your data center.
It's about storage.
It's about providing options
for storage, which emulate
local disk, whether that's a
durably replicated, reliable,
highly performant off-instance
storage, or whether it's
having access to large local
storage for data-centric
applications where you need
access to large, efficient,
local storage, to our
internet-scale cloud storage
offering, which provides the
ability to create shared
content in a cloud-scale or
internet-scale object store.
It's about network, being able
to take these virtual machines
and expose them to the network
so that you can access them
and to do that in such a way
that you have flexible control
over who can speak to them,
who can see them by using
flexible firewalls.
And it's also about being able
to fuse these virtual machines
together to form very powerful
compute clusters, so you can
tackle large-scale
data-processing problems the
same way Google does.
And then, of course, it's
about the tools.
You need to be able to command
and configure and control
these virtual machines.
And so we've provided a
portfolio of Tools options so
that you can jump in there and
configure them exactly the way
you want with a low-level
command-line tool.
Or you can access them
and get easy access
using a simple UI tool.
And we'll spend some time
jumping into these tools and
explaining the service
to you more.
And so what I'd like to
do is invite Chris up.
And I think the easiest way to
really understand the product
is just to see it.
That will really give you a
sense of what exactly this is.
So Chris will do a little
demo for us.
CHRIS: All right.
Let's flip these guys.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: There we go.
CHRIS: All right.
Thanks, Craig.
I'll be giving a brief tour of
our UI today, showing you
around a virtual machine
instance.
So let's go ahead and
dive right in.
We can look in the Google
Developer APIs site is where
our UI is located.
We have our compute nodes
here in the form of
virtual machine instances.
I only have a single instance
running right now.
We can look at our durable
storage in the form of
persistent disks that
we list here.
Again, just a single example.
And then our globally
available networks.
And right now, I just have my
default network defined here.
We also have our resource zones
and a list of operations
used for auditing what
actions have been
taken on your resources.
We'll get into those in
some later talks.
So all these are bundled
together in a
Google Developer project.
So here in the overview pane, we
can see that my project is
provisioned for 20,000
instances,
20,000 CPUs, et cetera.
So let's go ahead and
start an instance.
All right.
I like fractals, so I'll name
this guy Mandelbrot.
And I'm going to boot this with
an Ubuntu image that has
some fractal tools baked into
it, which I created just
before this talk.
I'm also going to turn
on a service account.
This enables seamless
authentication to other cloud
services that we have without
you needing to manage keys,
push keys into your VMs,
anything like that.
So we'll go ahead and get
that guy started.
So while that's spinning up,
it's worth noting that our UI
is actually an App Engine
application making calls
against Compute Engine's
public rest API.
There's no back doors
in use here.
We'll be open sourcing
this UI to you.
So you'll be able to use it as
the basis for specialized
platforms or more sophisticated
UIs.
In addition to this, I'll show
you a brief look at our
command-line tool written
in Python.
We will be open sourcing
that tool as well.
All right.
So we're up and running now.
I've got a SSH command line
here I can paste in.
And here we go.
I'm in my VM.
So we can poke around here, See
all the running processes.
We can see what kind of kernel
we're running on.
We can check out the CPU that's
in here, so a full
Linux virtual machine available
for you to use very
quickly, very easily.
I'm going to go ahead and have
this instance do a little bit
of work for me.
So he's going to generate
a series of
image tiles for a fractal.
And you can see here that
we're uploading these to
Google Cloud Storage using that
seamless service account.
And then as those tiles hit
Google Cloud Storage, I have a
local server picking them up and
displaying them here in a
pretty basic web UI, so
pretty quick and easy.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Thanks, Chris.
So as you see, we have gathered
a very simple Linux
virtual machine as a
service offering.
This is
Infrastructure-as-a-Service as
you'd expect it to be.
And I'd like to sort of
contextualize a little bit and
help you think about what we're
focused on, what the
value proposition of this
is from our perspective.
It comes down to this--
single bit Linux virtual
machines are great.
But what we do at Google is we
throw a lot of infrastructure
at problems.
So we've developed a set of
technologies, and we've
derived a tremendous amount of
benefit from having very large
amounts of accessible,
affordable infrastructure that
we can throw at large-scale
computing problems.
And in many ways, that's one of
the toughest challenges we
have to face.
It's like, how do we build a
service like this that can
really scale?
So that it enables you to tackle
problems the same way
we tackle problems on the same
infrastructure that we use.
So this first version of Google
Compute Engine, this
initial offering, is really
focused on large-scale compute
problems, helping you solve
these large-scale
data-processing problems.
And for us, that mean's
scalability, that means being
able to stand up these virtual
machine instances quickly so
that you can quickly bring up
one of these clusters, do your
work, and then turn it down
when you're done with it.
And it also means being able
to perform effectively.
It's not just about performing
fast in a straight line.
We actually have some pretty
cool toys that Urs has built
us over the last decade.
It's pretty easy to go fast
singly on this kind of
infrastructure.
We've really focused on being
able to do this at scale and
being able to perform better
the bigger and bigger the
cluster is.
And so that's some of the things
that's really unique
about this technology.
And then, of course, it's
about affordability.
If you're buying a large amount
of virtual machines,
you're buying a lot of CPU, you
want to be able to do that
affordability.
And we really think about
this is a utility.
You should be able to plug into
this thing, consume as
much resource as you want, just
like a utility, be able
to get that resource
affordability, just like you
do from a traditional
utility company.
Because that utility company is
able to deliver it at scale
and achieve very high
efficiencies of scale.
And so that's what Google
Compute Engine is about.
It's about bringing these
three things together--
scale, performance at scale,
and affordability.
All right.
I think to really understand the
service, it makes sense to
step back and describe some
of the guiding principles.
These are the architectural
principles that we used to
steer our design and steer every
decision we've made in
delivering the service.
I think it's useful
for two reasons.
One is it'll help you understand
the service better.
But it will also help
you understand where
the service is going.
Because these principles
are still in effect.
These principles
are driving our
day-to-day decisions today.
And they will continue to drive
them in the future.
And we believe that these
guiding principles are very
effectively manifest
in the service.
And as you get a chance to play
with it, as you get a
chance to use it, you'll
experience it for yourself.
And our first guiding principle
here, the thing that
trumps everything,
is security.
We recognize that your data
is your business.
And to win your custom, to win
your trust, we have to treat
that data with a tremendous
amount of respect, and we have
to create very strong controls
to ensure the security of your
data and to ensure the privacy
of your users.
And so at every stage of the
game, we focused on delivering
strong security controls.
A couple of examples of
this are our network.
Any data that transits between
virtual machines, whether
they're sitting on the same rack
right next to each other
or whether they're going
thousands of miles across
regions, runs on Google's
global private network.
It's secure.
There's very high levels of
encapsulation that we've
applied to ensure that no one
can intercept those packets or
to try to attempt to ensure
that no one can intercept
those packets and drive the
security of the system.
We also encrypt all
data at rest.
This is really important.
Our customers have
asked for this.
Our customers demand it, and
so we've provided it.
So any data that's written to
our block devices, whether
it's at the system block device
or our local disk, is
encrypted at rest.
And because we're doing that,
we're able to do that very
efficiently.
So you don't see noticeable
performance
impact of that control.
The next criteria that
we focused on is
tremendously important.
This is a little bit nuanced.
But it actually has steered us
and is probably one of the
most impactful things we've
really focused on.
And that's the idea
of consistency.
When you're building real-world
solutions, it pays
to be operating in a consistent
environment.
Traditionally, you have
to design for
the worst-case scenario.
Sometimes you don't even know
what that's going to be.
If you're operating in an
unstable environment, you have
to design in controls to deal
with rapid-order scaling, and
it adds a lot of degrees of
freedom to the solution.
And so at every stage of the
game, we focused on creating a
consistent environment.
Our target here is not a
massively multi-tenant cloud.
That's not what we're
trying to deliver.
Our target here is to deliver an
experience, an environment
that feels like you're
in a data center.
That's the class of consistency
that we're trying
to achieve.
And to support this, one of
the things we've been very
concerned about as we've seen
what's been happening in the
cloud is the movement away from
the separation of storage
and compute.
We've seen 20 years of sand
development, where enterprises
have moved to a world where
they're able to effectively
decouple these two things.
And it creates a great
degree of control and
flexibility for them.
It made us a little bit sad when
we observed that people
were moving to a world where
storage was getting pushed
back into the compute container
because the storage
block devices were just not
able to achieve the
performance and the consistency
of performance
necessary to meet
enterprise-level SLAs.
So that's one of the things
we've focused on
significantly, and we've paid
a tremendous amount of
attention to, is creating a
persistent block device that
offers better characteristics
in terms of performance,
better characteristics in
terms of throughput than
writing to our local block
device on disk.
And that's really
important to us.
The next principle, and this is
kind of obvious to us and
it's really steered
our decision, is
we have to be open.
We have to be flexible.
There's a tremendous amount of
code that exists out there.
People have invested probably
trillions of dollars in
developing code.
It makes sense for them to be
able to take that code and run
it in our data centers on this
awesome infrastructure.
And the open source community is
just this incredible source
of innovation.
It's a tremendously
innovative space.
We think our customers should
be able to take whatever the
open source community is
producing and be able to run
it on our infrastructure and
achieve the benefits of what
we're doing.
So we focused on creating
an open ecosystem.
We've also focused on things
like an open API.
As Chris mentioned, our tools
are all built on an open API.
We don't have any back doors.
There's no cheating.
You can get in there, and
you can extend our
stack at any level.
And we really like the idea of
being able to plug into our
stack at any level.
And it's also about
the ecosystem.
Our goal is to deliver
beautiful, pure,
high-performance, affordable
infrastructure.
And we really want to create
a vibrant, strong, partner
ecosystem that can deliver
great experiences when
managing this and great
experiences for our users when
they want to move workloads
around.
And then it's about being
proven, and being proven to us
means one thing, really.
This has to be a technology that
we're willing to bet our
own business on.
So as we've gone-- and it's
still early days for us with
the stack we're just bringing
it into the market now with
this initial offering.
But we are running Google
businesses on
this technology today.
So it's one technology for
internal businesses, and it's
one technology for the
outside business.
And it's the same technology.
One example of this
is Invite Media.
Urs mentioned it today.
And we're very lucky to have
Hansa, who will be talking in
a later tech session about their
experiences when moving
to this technology stack.
Long story short, they've
had a great experience.
They've been able to benefit
from the power, the consistent
power of the platform.
They've been able to reduce
the number of cores they
needed to actually run their
workload by half for similarly
configured instances.
And they've also been able to
benefit from the consistency
of experience, where some of the
variance that resulted in
some errors, in bidding in their
case, just went away
because of this much more
robust, consistent platform
than what they'd had previously
building in another
multi-tenant cloud
environment.
So I mentioned this when I was
talking a little bit about
being open.
And it's worth just
really calling out
to our partner ecosystem.
Again, we're focused on pure,
beautiful infrastructure.
We're not going to do all of
everything, certainly not
coming out of the gate.
And so being able to tap into
the power of the ecosystem,
being able to work with partners
that completed, that
create the best experiences
around managing and support
the mobility of workloads
between on-premises in the
cloud and between
clouds as well.
We believe very strongly that
you should be able to pick the
cloud that makes sense based
on the merits of the core
technology.
We feel that very strongly.
And so we've worked hard to find
a set of partners that
share those values and are able
to support that mission.
And ultimately for us, it really
comes down to this--
we're going to deliver you a
set of servers that you can
configure and run any
way you want.
We recognize that it makes
sense for you to be--
you probably want to think
about this in terms of
services, not servers.
And so this ecosystem is really
going to enable that
and support that idea.
So what I'd like to do now is
invite Michael Crandell, the
CEO of RightScale, on stage.
Here you go, Michael.
MICHAEL CRANDELL: Chris,
thank you very much.
Wow.
It is really great to be here
at the launch of Google
Compute Engine and on behalf of
RightScale to announce our
support for that.
We do have a live demo
for you today.
But before we launch into that,
a word about RightScale.
RightScale pioneered the whole
category of cloud management.
And our vision since we got
started five years ago was
really to open up this new world
of cloud services to
everyone by making it easier
and more efficient and more
reliable to run your apps and
workloads on low-level cloud
infrastructure resources, so
compute storage and networking
resources across a variety
of different providers.
And we do this by offering a
web-based, pretty broad cloud
management platform that
encompasses everything from
automation to configuration,
to monitoring, user
management, and so on and so
forth that really acts as an
environment that's a bridge
between your apps and
workloads and the low-level
infrastructures, whether
they're public clouds, or
private clouds, or hybrid
clouds that you want
to run them on.
And so over those five years,
we've gained a lot of
experience.
We've had lots of customers,
a lot of traction.
We've, on behalf of our
customers, launched more than
4 million servers
in the cloud.
We've also powered some of the
biggest scaling events that
have occurred.
And then finally, we've enabled
large migrations from
one cloud infrastructure to
another in excess of 20,000
different servers.
I'd like to highlight what we
think is really special about
Google Compute Engine, and
specifically three things that
we believe are our
differentiators.
The first one has to do with
the global private network
that Google is offering,
right?
I think we've all known for
some time that Google's
infrastructure is a key
part of the secret
sauce of the company.
And it's pretty amazing that
they're actually opening that
up to all of us to access and to
use on an as-you-go basis.
But this global private network,
which is part of it,
really enables global deployment
in a much more
easier fashion.
You've got basically what looks
like a private network
spanning the globe.
And specifically it makes
replication and disaster
recovery failure isolation
strategies much, much easier.
Second big point I wanted to
emphasize is fast boot times.
Why does that matter?
Well, it obviously matters
in terms of auto scaling.
When you need to scale up
quickly, the faster that
servers boot, the faster you
auto scale, but also in terms
of day-to-day buildup and
tear-down of environments that
we all use in the dev test
production life cycle.
And we've consistently seen
boot times of two minutes.
Very consistent, as Craig
mentioned, across the board,
loading from cloud storage.
Third area that I'd like to
emphasize is, harking back to
the point about security,
encrypting data at rest.
So we all know that security
is probably the top item on
the minds of larger companies.
But really it should be for all
of us as a requirement for
using cloud.
And because data is encrypted
at rest on storage to other
local volumes or
network-attached storage, it
couldn't be much simpler
or easier.
And there's virtually no impact
on the performance, so
very excited about that.
There are three things I wanted
to emphasize from
RightScale's point of view that
are core principles about
operating in the cloud that
we've embraced as a company
since we got started.
And I'd like you keep these in
mind as we get into the demo
in a second here.
The first one is what we
call usable stuff.
And what we mean by that is that
you, as developers and
users, should have access to
cloud-ready components that
you can get off the shelf, so
to speak, customize, if you
like, but put to work
very quickly.
Whether those are at a script
level, a recipe level, a
server template level, or
deployments of many, many
servers, you should be able to
just pick from a library, if
you will, and utilize
them quickly.
What comes out of that
is automation.
We really believe automation
is probably the key core
principle behind all of
this cloud revolution.
And it stems from the famous
concept of auto scaling all
the way through to the notion
of launching complex
multiserver deployments that
know how to configure
themselves as they come up.
And then finally, what we call
workload liberation.
And what we mean by that is
simply you should have freedom
of choice to run your apps and
workloads on whatever cloud
resource pool you choose
to based on your set of
requirements.
So those are three key
principles to keep in mind as
we launch into the demo.
And with that, I'd like to
invite my colleague Shivan up.
And we'll get right into it.
Shivan, can you tell us
what we have to see
today as a live demo?
SHIVAN BINDAL: Yes.
Thank you, Michael.
So we have a customer's typical
video transcoding
application that we're going
to walk through.
And this slide here just
kind of talks about the
architecture of this
application.
We're talking about taking
video files from the web,
creating transcoding jobs that
are then placed onto a queue,
and then having a multitude of
consumer servers taking those
jobs, downloading the videos,
transcoding them, and then
placing them for retrieval
from Google storage.
So they're actually sending
those video
files to Google storage.
Let's see what that looks
like in RightScale.
Here I have the RightScale
system.
And this is that single pane
of glass, Michael, that you
talked about, where you're
managing your cloud resources.
So we're talking about compute,
networking, and storage.
Here we have in the clouds menu
Google Compute Engine
connected to RightScale.
So I've provided my credentials
and made the
resources that Google makes
available available here in
RightScale.
And that's really where
RightScale starts in terms of
the cloud management
and automation
capabilities we offer.
MICHAEL CRANDELL: So can you
show us that automation at
work in the actual app?
SHIVAN BINDAL: So with any
application, you have a
variety of servers that comprise
that application.
And here what we're looking at
is the set of all servers for
this application.
We've got three different server
types, but really a
multitude of servers.
In RightScale, that is displayed
as a deployment.
So it's a collection of servers
for the use case here
of your application.
Three different types of
servers, as I mentioned.
We've got that producer who's
creating all the jobs.
We've got the queue
server that's
holding all of the jobs.
And then we've got the consumers
down here that are
running all the jobs and doing
all the transcoding.
Each of these types of servers
are running on top of what's
called a server template
within RightScale.
A server template is considered
a blueprint of how
your servers will reliably and
consistently be launched every
single time in the cloud so that
they are coming up with
the same state, with the same
configuration so that things
are actually usable.
And to really understand how
we're operating here at scale,
I've got about 325-odd
servers that are
running this workload.
And here you'll see with
RightScale's built-in
monitoring the capability that
that compute power provides.
So each of these graphs is a
single CPU from the servers
that we're looking at.
And the blue here shows the
actual load on the CPUs for
doing the video transcoding.
So, Michael, here you have, at
scale, an application running
on Google Compute Engine
managed via RightScale.
MICHAEL CRANDELL: So cool.
And by the way, audiences
normally
applaud at this juncture.
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CRANDELL: It's very,
very exciting to us.
So thanks for your
forbearance.
What else do we have to show?
SHIVAN BINDAL: Any application
is living and breathing.
This is one example of how you
might transcode some video.
But what happens if you have new
sources of video that you
need to start transcoding?
How quickly can you reuse this
environment for a new use case
or new instantiation of
the same application?
Well, with RightScale,
it's fairly simple.
I'm going to take what we call
the deployment, that
collection of servers,
and clone it.
By cloning it, I'm taking the
configurations that we had and
making them available for
configuration in the new case
or the new instance.
And what I'm going to do with
just a few clicks is I'm going
to start launching that entire
deployment of servers so that
they're available to start
doing these jobs again.
What I've just done is I've
enabled what RightScale calls
a server array, which has
all of those workers
now starting to launch.
And now I'm just going to go
ahead and launch up the queue
and video producer or the server
that's going to create
all these jobs.
I'm going to launch
that as well.
And what you're going to see--
I actually clicked it.
It does look like
it's clicked.
So what actually happens
now is you'll see these
servers come up.
And as this comes up--
it'll take a few
minutes to actually happen.
But from my perspective as
a user, that's all the
interaction I need
with RightScale.
You'll see they're already
in pending state.
And now, again Michael, these
325 servers plus these other
two servers that are doing a lot
of the command and control
stuff all launched through
RightScale.
MICHAEL CRANDELL: Thank you.
And on the left-hand side there,
you can see in the
events window the activity
starting to propagate.
Well, behind every demo there's
usually a little bit
of an interesting story.
Could you tell us the back-story
of what really
happened to put this together?
SHIVAN BINDAL: Two things that
I'd like to point out.
One is, as with any demo, we
were building this demo out as
we were completing our
integration with Google
Compute Engine.
And so--
funny story-- we built this
application on another cloud.
But with RightScale's technology
of server templates
and the configuration management
that we bring to
the table, it was fairly simple
for us to take that
application and launch it on
Google Compute Engine.
And it really just worked,
which was really very
fascinating and exciting.
The second point is we didn't
have a lot of time.
So when we built the application
to do the video
transcoding, we wanted to
keep things simple.
We started with using only one
core, making things very
streamlined in terms of
one video per job.
And so what that meant was we
ended up launching a whole ton
of instances or virtual machines
on Google Compute
Engine to do all of the work
for us and keep the
application layer very simple.
MICHAEL CRANDELL: So it makes
sense to make the
infrastructure do the work,
not the developers.
That probably resonates
with some of you
out there, that idea.
So just to prove the point
and show that we're doing
something real, can you show
some of the output that came
out of the transcoder?
SHIVAN BINDAL: So here I
have Google Storage,
Google Cloud Storage.
This is the storage browser
that's available by Google.
And anybody who has a project
and access to Google
Cloud can see this.
This is one of the videos
that we've transcoded.
And, well, we can play
it really quickly.
But what I wanted to highlight
is that we saw some really
great performance in terms of
the communication between
Google Compute Engine virtual
machines and Google Storage,
just very low-latent
connectivity
and very high bandwidth.
So it was very quick.
And to play this video,
let's see if I can
full screen it here.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-When we started working with
the team at Google, it was
very clear from the very
beginning that this is an
all-out effort.
This is serious.
This is worldwide.
This leverages the full depth
of Google engineering.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
MICHAEL CRANDELL: Cool.
There you have it.
That's the video.
[APPLAUSE]
MICHAEL CRANDELL: That, by the
way, is our CTO and co-founder
Thorsten, if you'll
wave your hand.
We're all around
through Friday.
We have a sandbox here.
We also have our private beta of
support for Compute Engine
at rightscale.com/google.
Very much looking forward
to partnering.
Thank you so much.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Wonderful.
Thank you, Michael.
It's wonderful that you can
deploy such large, complex
services with the click
of a button.
MICHAEL CRANDELL: Absolutely.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: And we also
love the fact you can move
between clouds, so--
MICHAEL CRANDELL: All right.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Thank
you for your time.
MICHAEL CRANDELL: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: All right.
So let's get into a little
bit more detail about the
technology and help you
understand some of the
specifics of what we're
actually doing here.
I'm gonna start off and just
walk through the stack.
And the logical place to start,
again, is Compute.
You've already seen the
virtual machines.
These are KVM-based machines.
So we were running on
the KVM hypervisor.
And we've worked pretty closely
with Red Hat for quite
a while to get to a point where
we have a very secure,
highly performant,
high-consistency environment
to host these class of
virtual machines.
We really appreciate the
leadership that Red Hat has
shown in this space.
And we'll continue to work
with them in the future.
These virtual machines are
available in multiple sizes,
so you can get them in one, two,
four, and eight cores.
And they come with 3.75
gigabytes of RAM per core.
So these are pretty beefy
virtual machines.
Our smallest virtual machines is
actually quite a lot bigger
than the smallest virtual
machines you'll see elsewhere.
So that's something to think
about as you actually look at
what we're doing.
And that makes sense here.
Because what we really focused
on is delivering
high-performance computing,
like lots of compute power
that you can access and tap
into just because of these
data-center characteristics.
And we offer two versions
of Linux.
We have Ubuntu and CentOS
out of the gate.
But you can actually take
whatever you want, any
Linux-based image, and create
bootable images and run what
you want to in this
environment.
Storage.
I mentioned this earlier, and
we have a variety of storage
capabilities to meet different
needs, two block devices that
enable you to run familiar
workloads that require a block
device to support them.
The first is persistent disk,
our off-instance, durably
replicated, storage medium.
This is a very high-consistency,
high-throughput solution that
enables you to store data
securely that lives beyond
the life of your
virtual machine instance.
So this is the place where you
would want to write stuff,
like if you wanted to run a
database, for example, this
would be a great backing
store for a database.
We also provide a kind
of cheap and
cheerful local disk option.
We recognize that our focus
workloads are very
data-centric.
So it makes sense to have access
to a lot of affordable
storage that's coupled to your
virtual machines to store data
that your processing
as a cache.
This data is bound to the life
cycle of your virtual machine.
So if you stop your virtual
machine, this data is
permanently gone because we
encrypted at rest, and that
key is only ever stored in
the virtual machine.
So when the virtual machine goes
away, the data goes away.
That's something to consider as
you're building solutions
on this technology, is
definitely If you have
something you want to store
beyond the life cycle of the
virtual machine, persistent
disk is the way to go.
And then there's Google
Cloud Storage.
Google Cloud Storage is our
enterprise-grade, internet
object store.
So this is the place you can go
to write objects that need
to be accessible by
the internet.
It has some really interesting
characteristics.
I'll pick on two of
them, but it's a
pretty interesting service.
The first characteristic is
that it benefits from our
global high-performance
network backbone.
So it almost comes with
a CDN baked in.
So the content that you want to
access will be replicated
to the place where you
need it and will be
accessible very quickly.
And we invite our customers
to try this out.
We think the performance
characteristics are really good.
The other thing that it offers
is read-your-write
consistency, which is an
interesting characteristic
when you're trying to build
a system at scale.
It's nice to have an object
store that you can write
content to with that level
of predictability.
And we found it very useful
as we've developed our own
solutions in this space.
Network.
Our network really shines.
It's one of things that
I think truly
distinguishes the service.
Our private network enables
you to fuse these virtual
machines together very
efficiently.
And it offers tremendous
network
cross-sectional bandwidth.
We really invite our early
customers to try this out.
We think this is going to be
something that's very distinct
about the service.
And we'll have a demo in a
little bit that kind of
showcases some of these
interesting performance
characteristics in this cloud.
And then, obviously, no virtual
machine stands alone,
so the ability to assign a
static IP address to the
machine that you can maintain
for a long time.
And these IP addresses
are actually global.
You can remap that IP address to
another machine in another
region that's the geographically
isolated.
And Google's network will just
take care of making sure that
the traffic gets to the
right location.
And then, obviously,
firewalls.
You have to be able to secure
your virtual machines.
You want to be able to control
who can access them.
So we have a very simple
intuitive firewall setup that
enables you to very specifically
control who talks
to what in the system.
And tooling.
Chris demonstrated our
tools briefly.
And he showed you the little UI
tool that we've developed.
And we think that's an
interesting metaphor for us.
It really shows and
demonstrates our
commitment to openness.
By all means, we're gonna make
that source code available.
It runs in App Engine.
We think App Engine's a great
environment to write this
class of management tool, to
control clusters, and to get a
view of the clusters.
So the fusion of those two
technologies together is
actually pretty powerful.
And then we have for the command
line and client, we
have a very nice little
command-line tool that
provides and exposes the full
flexibility of API.
And then, of course, we
have our partners.
Our partners are contributing
tremendously
to our tooling story.
They've enabled us to really
focus on getting the
infrastructure right, knowing
that folks that need a
best-of-breed management story
have someplace to go.
And with that, I'd like to
invite our friends from MapR
on stage to do a little demo.
And they're going to show--
as I mentioned, this service is
really about execution at
scale and experiencing the
power and efficiency of
Google's data centers to solve
some large problems.
And they have some really
interesting
technology to do just that.
JOHN SCHROEDER: All right.
Thanks, Craig.
And thanks to Google
for inviting us
to be up here today.
I'm John Schroeder.
I'm the CEO and co-founder
of MapR Technologies.
And MC Srivas is the chief
technology officer and founded
the company with me a little
over three years ago.
And actually, Srivas is
an ex-Googler as well.
So let's see, how do
I advance this?
So before I get into MapR, I
thought I'd give some of our
impressions of the Google
Compute Engine.
And when we first got access to
Google Compute Engine, the
engineers came to me the same
day and said John, this is
blazing fast.
Performance is really
important to MapR.
And we can tell it's
also important to
Google Compute Engine.
With our platform, we're able to
drive a lot of bandwidth to
disk and really drive network
bandwidth as well.
And we're impressed with
the performance there.
And then our technology runs on
large clusters of computers.
And we put a lot of effort into
building our own QA lab
internally to do testing of very
large deployments and our
customer base as well.
But with Google Compute Engine,
we could quickly spin
up 1,000, 1,200, 1,600 servers
in a matter of minutes and run
those types of scalable
applications.
And then finally, I got a
glimpse at the pricing over
the last few days.
And it's very compelling.
I think that it really
changes the game.
And any organization that's
looking to move some or all of
their on-premise computing into
the cloud really should
take a hard look at Google
Compute Engine.
So we're going to use MapR to
demonstrate some of the speed
and scale of Google
Compute Engine.
So let me tell you a little
bit about MapR.
We're a provider of an open
enterprise-grade Hadoop
distribution.
So we really take Hadoop and
really have transformed it
into a very reliable compute
platform and
dependable data store.
We've done a lot of
standards-based extensions to
Hadoop to really broaden
the use cases
it's appropriate for.
We've got deployments at
thousands of companies,
customers in most of the major
vertical market segments,
including financial services,
a lot of Web 2.0, telco,
federal government, aerospace,
and such.
If you don't know what Hadoop
is-- probably most of you do,
it's pretty popular--
but it's a big data analytics
platform.
So it's a platform for being
able to run analytics at a
very large scale, petabytes or
even 100 petabytes of data.
And that data may be structured
or semi-structured.
It runs generally on commodity
hardware in
large clusters of computers.
And since we're at a Google
conference, we want to make
sure that we also identify that
really the whole Hadoop
project was inspired by a paper
about MapReduce that was
published by a couple of Google
scientists back in
2004, Jeffrey Dean and Sanjay.
And we're really happy to have
MapR now running as part of
the Google Compute Engine.
So a few days ago, Craig said
could you put together a demo
that would show some of
the capabilities of
Google Compute Engine?
Also, it'll allow you to show
your product a bit, too.
So Srivas and I talked.
And he said, well, why don't
we just run a big sort?
And TeraSort is a standard
benchmark that's run to
measure performance
of applications.
And it's a very popular
benchmark for demonstrating
the performance of Hadoop
distributions.
So we stitched together quickly
a 1,250-node cluster
and ran a TeraSort.
And I think we'll do a demo of
that right now, and Srivas can
walk you through how
that worked.
MC SRIVAS: So what we have here
is each of these green
squares represents a node in
the Google Compute cluster.
So we have a full cluster of
about 1,250 nodes with five
control nodes.
And this is the heat map that
we have, which lets you look
at the cluster from one console
and put different
views on it.
And one of the views we're
putting on out here will be,
how does the CPU load on the
system when we run a TeraSort?
And, of course, it turns from
green to red and back again.
On the other side is the actual
TeraSort benchmark.
It's a command line that shows
the elapsed time as it runs.
So what's very impressive
about this was-- let
me start this up.
So here we are launching
a TeraSort.
And as you can see, it fans
out the work to all
the nodes very fast.
The Google Compute network
was incredibly efficient.
We could just go and load up the
clusters almost instantly.
A TeraSort runs within
a minute.
And so you have to go and load
up about several thousands of
computers almost instantly with
data and then have them
all do a criss-cross section
of the data going across.
And then you can see
how there's no
nodes that are green.
Every node is lit up well.
And what it shows is the
cross-cluster bandwidth of
thousands of machines talking
to each other in a complete
crossbar working really well.
So this was kind of an
interesting benchmark because
if you had told me this three
months ago, hey, do this
benchmark on a cloud, I would
have said ha, I mean, you can
never do this.
And when we were invited to work
on Google Compute Engine,
we were just blown away by its
performance, its scale, how
easy it was to deploy.
And we literally thought of this
last week, doing this.
And to pull this off in a week,
we could not have done
without the ease, the
simplicity, and the
reliability, and the consistent
performance of
Google Compute.
It is just incredible.
So it's still finishing.
Usually the problem is the last
stragglers take a long time.
So this took about a minute, I
think 80 seconds, a minute and
20 seconds, and it's
probably--
I'll hand this off to John
to talk about what's
the impact of this.
JOHN SCHROEDER: OK, so if you
look at running TeraSort, the
fastest TeraSort I'd seen
recorded on physical hardware
is described in the middle
column there.
And it was deployed at 1,460
physical servers running on
bare metal Linux with a high
number of disks, 5,800 disks,
and almost 12,000 cores.
And that's a record that took
a long time for a company to
put together in their own
internal data center to run.
Here in a really short period
of time in a virtual
environment running on fewer
servers, 1,256 servers, one
disk per server and about 5,000
cores, we're right in
the neighborhood with that.
So I'd love to come back here
next year and maybe raise the
bar and do a petabyte benchmark
instead, but a
really great performance.
And on on-premise Hadoop
implementations, they rarely
run in virtualized environments
because of the
performance overhead.
So it's also another indication
of the performance
of Google Compute Engine.
[APPLAUSE]
JOHN SCHROEDER: Now, if you look
at putting this together,
those two benchmarks, if you
tried to assemble 1,460
servers in your data center,
it'd take you months.
I mean, I'd be negotiating with
my server vendor probably
for months.
And then I'd have to rack and
stack 50 to 70 racks of
servers, switching our
infrastructure, get the
electrical brought into the
data center to handle that
server load, probably 50 to 75
tons of air conditioning.
So it's a massive project.
It'd take just months to do.
And with the Google Compute
Engine, we're basically up and
running on over 1,200 instances
in a matter of minutes.
So the time to deploy
is very, very fast.
And then, if you noticed, we're
not paying for that
anymore now either.
Once we're done running the
TeraSort, we give those
resources back to Google,
where with the physical
servers, they'd be mine.
And three to five years from
now, I'd have to swap all
those servers out for
newer models.
And we leave all that
to Google as the
cloud provider as well.
And from a cost perspective,
just to
take a really, really--
[LAUGHTER AND APPLAUSE]
JOHN SCHROEDER: Just a very
conservative run.
If I just allocate 4,000 a
server, which is probably 50%
lower than what most Hadoop
servers go for.
And this doesn't count racks,
PDUs, switching
infrastructure, ongoing OPX,
yeah, $6 million, a minute 20
of instance time?
$16.
So a tremendous cost
advantage.
Finally we are part of
the private beta.
If you'd like to try running
MapR Hadoop on Google Compute
Engine, really simple
URL to remember--
Mapr.com/Google.
So thanks much for your time.
Thank, Craig.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Thanks, John.
Thank you.
That's a great demo.
And I'm definitely looking
forward to having you come
back and do some more
interesting stuff with our
data centers.
And this is really early
days for us.
This is the first offering
of the service.
It's just going to keep
getting better.
We're going to bring more
and more of the awesome
infrastructure technologies of
Google to you so that you can
benefit from them and benefit
from the efficiencies.
So John already talked about
this a little bit.
A big part of our commitment
with the service is to
transfer the efficiencies
we benefit to you.
And then we believe this is
reflected in our price sheet.
If you take a look at
this price sheet,
it may not be obvious.
But when you look at this
compared to what other cloud
providers are offering, you get
up to 50% more compute for
your money.
And we really invite you to get
on board, try this out,
and take a look at it.
That standard, that one, is
not a small instance.
There's a whole bunch of compute
power in that thing.
So we definitely want you
to take a look at it.
Take it for a spin and see if
you experience the same kind
of benefits of that we've seen
when running our processes on
these things.
And with that, I do thank
you for your time.
And I invite you to join our
limited preview program.
We're available now.
And I expect there'll be a fair
amount of demand because
access to the program comes with
a pretty generous quota
of free compute.
And so while we have very, very
big data centers, we do
have finite spots in our compute
program, so we beg
your patience.
And do apply, and we'll try to
service everyone who wants to
participate in this program.
For folks that reach the end and
really like the service,
it will be available
commercially.
And we will be offering
an SLA.
support to
our commercial customers.
So you can absolutely contact
our sales team, and they'd be
delighted to speak to you about
the service, tell you a
little bit more about it,
and tell you about
how to get this program.
And so go ahead and do
apply for access.
And we invite you to come
to some other sessions.
If you want to learn more about
Google Compute and you
want to get into some of the
details, Joe Beda, who's the
technical lead, one of the
original architects on the
project, will be delivering a
session called 313 at 5:30
this afternoon.
And then tomorrow, we'll have
another session, 308, which
will really clarify the
relationship between Google
Compute Engine and Google App
Engine and help you understand
how to build very powerful
systems that bring together
the best of
Platform-as-a-Service and
Infrastructure-as-a-Service in
the Google Cloud platform.
And with that, I'd like to
invite my colleagues on stage.
We'll do a little Q&A. I think
we have about 10 minutes.
So if you have questions,
please let us know.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: It's obvious that it
does scale very quickly.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But what about certain
applications that need
32 cores on one machine?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: So yes,
it does scale quickly.
Right now, we offer instance
sizes up to eight cores.
We're absolutely looking at ways
to bring even more of our
infrastructure capabilities
to market.
But that's just where
we started.
So right now, it's really about
lots of work that can be
paralyzed, and we will
provide vertical
scaling in the future.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So when MapR showed
their cost calculation of $16,
they actually broke
it down by second.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So are you going
to be billing at seconds,
minutes, or to the hour?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: It's
a great point.
At this point, it's
by the hour.
So what they really should have
said is you could have
done this 60 times in
a row for this.
Right now, it is on demand
by the hour.
But that's definitely something
we're thinking about.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
AUDIENCE: My question is about
how it plays well with Google
App Engine, specifically on the
areas of load balancer.
So once I've integrated it with
Google App Engine, will
it work with the same
authentication?
The second being how it
works with memcache.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: OK.
So obviously, we have two
technologies, Google App
Engine and Google
Compute Engine.
We're going to be doing
a session tomorrow.
We'll get into much more
of the details.
But I'll provide you a very
brief sense of where we are.
Coming out of the gate, Google
Compute Engine is about being
able to deploy a lot of
service to solve some
computationally hard problems.
App Engine is our web-facing,
high-productivity,
high-efficiency environment for
application development.
The two together actually
work pretty well.
We have the ability to flow
credentials using OAuth so
that you can use service
accounts to authenticate
across them.
And App Engine becomes a very
natural orchestrator and
management framework for these
Compute containers.
And the Compute offers the
ability to open App Engine up
and run general workloads that
can connect as part of your
App Engine application.
Now over time, we will work
to create even richer
connectivity between
the two services.
For now, it works
very naturally.
And a great example
of that is our UI.
That was an App Engine
application.
application that was just
spinning up these virtual
machines.
So App Engine's a very natural
way to do things like order
scaling and to deal with some
of those constituent parts.
And it'll just get
better with time.
Hope that answered
your question.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Are the data centers located
internationally?
And if so, can I specify
a fail oversight?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: So at this
point, we only have domestic
data centers, US data centers.
We are working on creating a
global data center footprint.
AUDIENCE: Even within the US,
can I specify a fail oversight
in East Coast or West Coast?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yeah,
you can pick.
We actually publish what
region they're in.
And so you can pick which
specific data center you want
to be deployed in, so
that you can be
close to your customers.
We're launching initially with
three data center locations
that are centered on and East
Coast, which works well for
this class of workload.
And we're looking at bringing on
more as the service matures
and as we bring more
capabilities to market.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I saw in the flow diagram that
there were connections to the
outside world from the VMs.
But I didn't see anywhere in
the API console when he
flipped through that showed like
IP address allocation or
anything like that.
Is there--
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Oh yeah.
So go ahead, Joe.
JOE BEDA: I'm going to be
talking about that a lot more
in my session at
5:15, not 5:30.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Oh,
was it 5:15?
Sorry.
I apologize.
JOE BEDA: But yeah we do provide
public IP addresses,
IPv4 addresses that are mapped
one-to-one to instances.
And you can either have those
be statically allocated and
attached to your project,
or you can have those be
ephemeral, and they
come and go with
that particular instance.
AUDIENCE: How do we sign up?
[LAUGHTER]
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Go to
cloud.google.com, press the
button, and do it quick.
JOE BEDA: I just want to drive
home the point that these
things, these IP addresses,
are actually
global across our service.
So they can float from region to
region, which we think is,
especially going towards the
disaster recovery or failover,
it's an important feature
for that.
AUDIENCE: By what time do you
expect that a small business
can rent out, like let's say
around 10 servers of--
medium-size servers?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Smaller
locations.
So we're in limited
preview right now.
Folks that have workloads that
we think will really benefit
from the scale and efficiencies
of the data
centers we will take on board
and we'll take on as
commercial customers.
Based on our experiences with
the limited preview program,
as we grow this up, we will
decide when to make the
product generally available.
So our aspiration is to make it
available soon, but we want
to create a great experience
for all our customers.
And we think that the best
experience will be with these
large-scale workloads
right now.
AUDIENCE: But is it probable
that by the next Google I/O
you'll be there?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: I'm not going
to make any statements about
our future, so I'm sorry.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Good try.
Can you touch on how you would
upload a lot of data, what
tools are available, if it's
GSUtil based or FTP?
Or if you have a lot of data
that you want to move up to
disk, how that whole
process works?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yeah.
So as you've heard, all of our
services interact on the
Google global network.
So we have pretty high-capacity
pipes to Google Storage.
And from in the virtual machine,
you're actually able
to get OAuth credentials
seamlessly.
Our version of GSUtil, for
instance, seamlessly will just
reach into our metadata server,
grab some OAuth
credentials, and then enable
you to grab content from
Google storage very quickly.
So it's a very easy way
to deal with this.
It also means you don't have to
deal with pushing keys into
virtual machine images
and manage them.
So that we think is a
great experience.
And then again, it's on
the Google network.
We have some pretty interesting
network
technology.
AUDIENCE: Right.
But getting data before it's
on the Google network, so--
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yeah, so if
you can get to the Google
network, awesome
things happen.
AUDIENCE: So for many
high-performance computing
jobs that utilize a
heterogeneous compute
environment that includes GPUs
as well as a traditional CPUs,
does Google have
any plans for a
heterogeneous compute product?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: I mean,
obviously, there's a lot of
workloads that benefit from
GPU acceleration.
We don't yet have an offering.
And I can't really talk about
our GPU futures at this point.
But we do recognize the value
proposition of that.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thanks.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: I was going to ask
a GPU question as well.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: OK, so
pick another one.
AUDIENCE: How many--
what's the maximum number of
cores in the largest instance?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: The maximum
number of cores in the largest
instance is eight.
And those are pretty
beefy cores.
So you actually get quite a lot
of compute power for that.
We'll look at vertical
scalability and providing
bigger options in time.
But we figure that's a really
good place to start.
AUDIENCE: Sometimes with
continuous delivery, we need
to spin up rapidly a large
number of servers all at once.
Do you guys have any
kind of limits or
delays in large requests?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: What do
you believe is large?
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Um, say, 50, 100.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Yeah,
no, that's not--
I mean, that is a lot of
servers, but it's not that
many servers.
AUDIENCE: What is your limits
around some kind of delays?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Well, we tend
do think in the tens of
thousands at this point.
MALE SPEAKER: The API itself is
currently limited to about
20 QPS in our initial
offering.
JOE BEDA: Per project.
MALE SPEAKER: Per project.
Not total.
JOE BEDA: Not total.
[LAUGHTER]
MALE SPEAKER: No.
And then we'll be
spinning that up
as the service matures.
We're also going to look at
improving the APIs to do more
operations in batches.
So you could make a single
request for N
instances or N disks.
JOE BEDA: So it's good,
and it'll get better.
AUDIENCE: So for application
service, we may have the
internal load balancer.
Do you provide that?
So different--
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: So for
applications, you're looking
at a sort of elastic
load-balancing capability?
AUDIENCE: Yeah, load balancing
for internal so internal one
cluster can talk to another
cluster but is on the internal
access mode.
JOE BEDA: That's not something
that we're offering right out
of the gate.
But it's definitely an
architectural pattern that
we've seen.
And it mirrors a lot of what
we do internally at Google
also where you'll have different
tiers of your
application using load-balancing
technologies.
And we're going to keep looking
to see how we can
apply Google's experience, not
just at the hardware level,
but also at the software and
distributed system levels to
start solving problems
like that.
AUDIENCE: OK, thanks.
JOE BEDA: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: You guys
have mentioned a
lot about your network.
What kind of between-instance
latency do you have compared
to, say, EC2?
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: So it's
a great question.
We are very proud of our network
capabilities, and it
will continue to get even
more awesome with time.
We don't like to publish
comparative performance numbers.
We invite you to apply for
the program, try it out.
We think you'll like it.
We think you'll like it
particularly when you try to
build large clusters and you
want to see very strong,
consistent cross-sectional
bandwidth
across large clusters.
AUDIENCE: Will the App Engine
team ever be developing on top
of the Compute Engine?
So provisioning for App Engine
using the Compute Engine.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: So the question
is App Engine, will
they be building on top
of Compute Engine?
So at this time, the two
technologies work well
together, and we've ensured a
good degree of integration.
But they are discrete
products.
I mean, Google Compute Engine is
pure infrastructure, and it
benefits tremendously
from having that
Platform-as-a-Service
component.
Over time, I expect you'll see
the lines become more blurred.
And we're working on creating a
much more natural fusion of
the technologies.
For now, the best applications
are, for instance, using App
Engine as a way to build and
scale and manage large-scale
applications and serve as
a front end for those
large-scale Compute clusters,
and then using Compute Engine
to open up App Engine and run
proprietary code, for
instance, like a transcoding
application, et cetera.
And over time, I think
you'll find them--
well, we're working on making
them much more aligned.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: IPv6.
What are your plans
for offering it?
JOE BEDA: We are going
to do IPv6.
We had to prioritize what's
important to people now, right
now, as we worked to get the
product ready for Google I/O.
But Google is a very big
proponent of IPv6.
And I can guarantee you that
there are many people inside
of Google who would love to see
us have IPv6 yesterday.
So yeah, it's a priority
for us.
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: Absolutely.
Right.
Any other questions?
Wonderful.
Well, thank you so much
for your time.
[APPLAUSE]
CRAIG MCLUCKIE: And do visit
us in the later sessions.
Joe's session at 5:15.